[Applause]
[Music]
so jason mamoa who plays call jericho
came back for a cameo
scene with daenerys targaryen played by
amelia jason was one of our favorite
people ever on the show
and very very strong and that's not
that's not tv
makeup i mean just just in real life
he's just a big strong dude anyway we're
all out drinking
because we were celebr i mean we hadn't
seen jason in a year yeah
i'm looking at mamoa i'm is talking
about beating someone at the slap game
god take you at the slap game call drogo
in a physical contest yeah who could
pass that up
exactly i'm gonna challenge the call
because if i beat the call on the call
so david challenges jay to this game and
i've had some beers there's like an
anesthetic
quality of fear so we start going and i
got in a few pretty good slabs and then
i missed
and then it was my turn so i put my
hands out and he started slapping
i was looking at someone else probably
amelia alfie was sitting next to her and
i was looking at them
in the background there's just this book
and after about 10 of them you realize
that it hasn't
stopped probably he didn't he wasn't
missing and your conversation's been
going on with this
kind of firecracker sound going off and
i looked over
his hands were bright red and he was
still going
and that was when all of us decided to
put our conversation on hold and
to watch this contest yeah i looked in
my moa's eyes
i saw no mercy there but i wouldn't quit
because you know i had my pride i had my
gun friday
my hands hurt you even think
yeah when we looked down to his hands
his hands didn't look
right his hands were a lot bigger than
than his hands
normally are but you know i just thought
it was one of those things where it's
like it looks pretty bad
yes they look like catchers myths with
bubonic plague on them but but it's
gonna be better tomorrow
so i told jason i think you think you
won this one so the morning after this
slap game
i woke up in my bed in belfast and my
hands had doubled in size overnight and
they now
were truly ludicrous and i had to get on
a plane and fly back to los angeles so i
did and i flew back with my um catcher's
mid-hands
and i finally got home after this long
flight and walked up to my doorway and
there was my wife
and our baby girl and she saw me and i
was kind of like trying to hide my hands
a little bit but it
didn't work because they were so
monstrous and she said you're going to
the hospital
and she drove me down to the emergency
room since i couldn't drive we waited
for the doctor and finally
she saw us and she looked at them she
said what happened and i said i played
the slap game with jason momoa and then
she said okay let's do some x-rays and
she came back and her diagnosis was that
jason momoa had squished my hands it got
squashed
so it just goes to show don't challenge
the call
you